never better stand down
did that movie just change your life it
changed my life we all saw it was great
my next sentence will include spoiler so
if you do not want to spoiler get out of
the room now I'm only continuing to talk
to give you time to get out okay they're
gone the end of the movie we meet the
New Avengers did you know this there's
an alternate ending what wait no yes I'm
drew Coolidge and we've got the scoop on
that alternate ending this is hashtag
news okay still in spoiler mode in fact
why would you even be watching it if you
didn't want spoilers are you trying to
hurt yourself the title tells you that
there's spoilers it here we go so at the
end of age of Ultron we see Hulk Iron
Man Hawkeye Thor all going their
separate ways while Black Widow and
Captain America begin training the next
generation of Avengers
this new avengers lineup includes
familiar faces like war machine and
Falcon and new ones Scarlet Witch and
vision but it's well known that the
creators of this film actually shot
different versions of this same scene
with an alternate lineup specifically
Captain Marvel the lady version is
featured in place of one of the other
heroes other rumored characters include
Black Panther she-hulk the wasp even
possibly spider-man though I doubt they
shot anything with the new spider-man
considering they haven't even cast it
yet now there are other theories as to
what the alternate ending could be
including one where Hulk gets thrown
into space and happens to land on a
planet called Planet Hulk which is
convenient to have a planet named after
you that you land on unless they named
it after him once he lands I don't know
I don't think it's gonna happen now
considering that the alternate team
footage was actually shot we're pretty
confident this will be the alternate
ending but either way we'll know for
sure when the blu-ray drops with the
alternate ending and 30 minutes of other
deleted scenes that's it for us here at
hashtag news comment with who you think
should be the new generation of Avengers
hit like if you like this shirt hit like
if you hate this shirt we'll just put
both those again and subscribe for more
epic superhero news from new media
rockstars we're gonna let you guys know
all the news before the news knows the
news that's a promise
I'm drew Coolidge and here's an
alternate ending to this video I'm drew
Coolidge the Lady version and I'm really
ugly no don't say that